euromaxx highlights and here's your host
guy in hempstead greetings from the
German capital and a warm welcome to our
highlights of the weekend before we kick
off this show let's have a quick look at
some of our top stories resounding ruins
disused industrial sites get a new lease
on life outdoor eats join a barbecue
course with the experts
and Baltic highlights spotlighting the
Latvian dance and music festival or once
upon a time the Ruhr Valley in western
Germany was this country's industrial
heartland that was until about the 1980s
when the coal and steel industries there
went into decline well the area then
became an industrial wasteland until
some enterprising people began to use it
as a compelling backdrop for cultural
events now that whole idea has since
been copied in other places like in the
state of zeeland in the southwest and an
old industrial landscape there has now
become the perfect setting for a huge
techno festival a modern music festival
at a World Heritage Site
dj's lanka mood is warming up the crowd
at the electromagnetic festival last
year it was judged the best new festival
in Europe that may have had a lot to do
with the festival site the former flu
clinger ironworks in the state of czar
lund it's perfect tense to meet Huygens
there's a lot of Steel another metal
that has an effect on people Gladys
baboon its a mix of old and new culture
it's totally cool jakub giltner alias DJ
funky mood is one of the festival's main
attractions last year one of his remixes
was top of the charts in Germany Austria
and Switzerland as long as if I'd the
whole design of the place and the
industrial atmosphere is really
impressive technos essentially
industrial music anyway so it's
appropriate to play it at a place where
people used to work yeah altima machine
heads Bobby Tom Lord apartments got
you're always asking us how come Germany
produces so much electronic music a lot
of it comes from northern England that's
where it started Belgium tube those are
all industrial regions people live there
have absorb the pulse on the metal
machinery in the factories it's in their
heads it's even under DNA the Lords of
invented in hardness they produced iron
and steel here for nearly 100 years the
plant was closed in 1986 and became a
world heritage site in 1994 mine rod
gray Vinick is head of the facility the
fur clinger site is the world's last
fully preserved Industrial Age Iron
Works it covers six hundred thousand
square meters clay Vanek is committed
not only to preserving the facility but
also to breathing new life into it with
cultural events for example an
exhibition with internationally renowned
street artists epic I of Melissa we
consider the Iron Works and offspring of
pop culture these are poop quit would
pop art has always had a strong focus on
industry in mass production
it was through its association with pop
culture that this side which was once a
centre of industrial production as now
for the first time become a cultural
symbol bhagavad during the industrial
age factories were overheated noisy and
dirty the working conditions were tough
in coking plants Cole was heated to
temperatures of up to 1200 degrees
Celsius back in the 1960s the focalin
ironworks employed up to 17,000 people
after World War two the rural coal and
steel plants faced heavy competition
from overseas with the result that they
were being shut down one after the other
this huge gas ometer in the ruhr valley
town of oberhausen has been converted
into an exhibition space right now it's
featuring works by the famous bulgarian
born artist Cristo last weekend the roar
district celebrated its annual culture
festival called extra shift or extra
shift more than 200,000 people attended
the Kaaba saps know when I was younger I
worked at various mines and coca plants
so when I come to the cultural events
here at X fascist it's like reliving the
past it's a lot of fun Smosh pass it
doesn't show you d they could have just
tone it down and put up a stupid
shopping centre but they preserved it
and I think that's great pavan want no
knutson since old one of the festival
events was held at the hind researcher
works in Huntington actors staged a
noisy performance using tools from a
bygone age
old industrial sites in Germany have
undergone a transformation in recent
years they've become an artistic
inspiration for some a performance stage
for others the work was hot and dirties
but there was also a sound to it and the
workers took that sound home with them
and woke up with it it was part of her
life spot asleep and this transformation
of former industrial sites continues in
other countries too for example six
facilities in Britain have now been
designated World Heritage Sites compared
to four in Germany occasionally part of
the science revert to their natural
state like here at the filling or
ironworks here in the back vegetation
has been growing wild for years so a
landscape architect turned the area into
a series of 12 garden areas this is our
paradise it's a really special place the
coking plant was a hellish place but now
25 years after the plant was shut down
nature has reclaimed this part not so
hood but once a year techno music fans
take over the former Iron Works 10,000
people gather here to dance and enjoy
themselves until the early morning hours
that seven thousand fewer people than
used to work here but at least modern
culture has provided a new lease on life
for these industrial ruins well if you
think you're not the type to get excited
by architecture than I'd be willing to
bet that Pete had some tour might just
change your mind the swiss architect
started out in the late 1950s as a
carpenter and that means that he has a
very tactile relationship with his
materials on his latest project now pays
some hommage to those beginnings
the brain against forest at the western
tip of Austria has a new building for
trades and tradesmen it brings skills
and knowledge under one roof the
building's designer swiss architect
Piazza mwah explains the idea behind
this latest creation closed turkic
fantastic refresh open and proud that's
what I felt it had to be here you don't
have the building providing the space
and then going off on its own here the
building creates the space well skipper
did all the massive roof made of wood
and metal stands out the interior is
spacious and open the building is
located on the main street of the town
of Una's boo it was designed as a vast
showcase for the trades painted some
tour is from a family of tradesmen his
own professional career began with a
carpentry apprenticeship ripple maja
hobos when you make furniture even as a
boy you learn something very basic about
structural engineering more than with
mathematics at school I know for
instance that a chair leg of such and
such a form and size will stand
architecture of course is a lot bigger
but the principles are the same
representatives a principal some tour
made his name internationally with his
designs for the spa complex in fuzz as
well as the cool uma Museum in Cologne
and the brother Klaus field Chapel in
2008 he received the Japanese premium
imperiale for his life's work and in
2009 the klitzke prize perhaps the
greatest recognition of all for an
architect he got to know many of the
tradesmen from the play against forest
during construction of the kunst house
there so doesn't those who thought that
was the beginning of a number of
friendships we have great respect for
each other and we have some very close
friendships one result is that I
received this contract and the
confidence it implies straight away well
they just thought come on let's get some
tar for it let's excelled if all goes to
top though the vac combat against of
IDEs is a tradesman's co-op of some 80
companies for many different trades most
are carpenters but there are also
builders metal workers and Taylor's the
internationally renowned trades and form
competition is held every three years as
a way to inspire the next generation
they disowned fault on a hog if the sons
of all the tradesmen become lawyers and
only one is left who knows how to do
this then good craftsmanship can hardly
be had for any price that person would
be paid like a high-powered attorney we
don't want that to happen this is a
counter-movement caiga vivek dota2 Magos
Feist is a carpenter who's very
interested in keeping the trades and
their traditions alive he's been a
member of the vac home since it was
founded in nineteen ninety nine he's the
second generation in his family to run
the cabinet makers shop in neighboring
hit us all he gives sustainability a top
priority using wood from the region cut
according to an old tradition only
during certain phases of the Moon
this is gross avisan the great store of
knowledge about this wood and its
origins here in the immediate area the
qualities you need for various uses what
works perfectly and what second best you
can't write that down it has to be
passed on from one generation to the
next in one long interconnected
tradition for these traits to survive
it's vital that they remain affordable
handmade kitchen shouldn't cost much
more than one ready made from the
furniture store cherez reminiscent of
milking stools and prize-winning cutting
boards made by feist shop are part of
the exhibition opening on july twenty
first in the vac tom house works by all
80 members can be seen the show the pub
to get you this is something that's very
much alive there are women and children
taking part Oh there'll be a tradesman's
table a little restaurant and a bar
that's life and joy that's holistic
at the opening festivities pay debts on
tour is the guest of honor and a big
part of the region's tradesmen's culture
well if you think about it it's how the
whole concept of cooking began charring
meat over a fire and maybe that's why
barbecue season has such a special
flavor to it but we have come a long way
in the barbecue pros of today no longer
have to chop the wood or fuss with messy
charcoal and as the equipment has
evolved will so have the possibilities
and so we got some inspiration at a
gourmet grill academy in southwestern
Germany juicy steak with green pea
frittatas hamburgers with dried tomatoes
and sweet onions and Scottish Filat of
salmon with wild berry garnish it's not
what you'd expect to be offered at the
average barbecue in Germany these 20
people 19 men and one woman are taking
part in a course to widen their culinary
repertoire they've been I love
barbecuing I cook all kinds of things
but I think I'll learn a lot here let's
get on vonage for me it's about having
fun together oblivion I'd like to have a
go at some of these dishes at home the
marinated sausages the steaks or the
salmon which ones i was gonna Matt was
popular the courses are held in a former
monastery in the town of ingelheim in
southwestern Germany by Chef Bart moose
he says good outdoor cooking requires
the proper techniques whether the BBQ is
wood-fired gas-powered or electric most
food should be cooked over indirect heat
with the lid on that issue as the food
cooks faster and more evenly there are a
few tricks to improve the flavor too as
it doesn't these are cedar wood planks
they've been soaked in water you can use
them for smoking wherever you cook on
them acquires a smoked flavor
these days the work is made easier by
high-end equipment specialist stores
like this one in minds sell all kinds of
gadgets to make the experience more
convenient including designer grills
fancy tongs and recipe books vapors
complete BBQ book is a best-seller in
Germany but customers invest most in the
grill itself a good one can cost
thousands of euros and be a status
symbol man leafy by mottled us weird if
it's like when your neighbor went out
and bought an expensive car today the
neighbor gets a high-end grill and to
keep up with the Joneses you find
yourself wanting 120 baguette back to
bottom uses BBQ school for him and his
colleague Aaron good flush first class
outdoor cooking begins with a shopping
trip and not just to the butcher's they
consider variety to be the spice of
barbecuing life among consoles I can
barbecue anything whatever you can cook
in a kitchen you can cook on a grill the
only thing I don't grill is pastor but I
barbecue everything else cake bread meat
vegetables fish anything and everything
that occurs to me head even ice cream
has found its way onto the grill of the
belgian-born cook for dessert the course
participants are making barbecued ice
cream bombs the frozen interiors are
completely coated with whipped egg white
before being popped on the grill for a
few moments
logoart was an easygoing atmosphere
delicious cooking it was a great evening
like moth optus Robin the dessert was
totally new for me cooking ice cream on
a grill everything else was delicious
and interesting turn after the desert
the lessons may be over but the
fledgling barbecuers are just getting
started they'll take with them plenty of
new recipes to try out at home singing
is good for you and there are lots of
studies to prove it which may just mean
that Latvians are particularly healthy
because practically everyone in Latvia
sings there's a very strong coral
tradition there that's been nourished
for centuries in every five years they
hold a spectacular song and dance
festival the grand finale of the Latvian
song and dance festival in the capital
Riga brought a chorus of tens of
thousands of people together among them
amateur singer ELISA bommana and
conductor in stature off skis very sick
fish it was a fantastic experience
everyone the audience to was seeing
along if you are loved sales mr. gosh it
was just a fabulous feeling the audience
held out in this heat listening to us
for hours I'm overwhelmed a few days
before Ali Sabbagh mana hurried to one
of the final rehearsals for the grand
finale it's Iowa i got up at 5am got to
the office at seven worked for nine
hours and now i'll be rehearsing for
three hours listo
her choir normally practice is three
times a week but in the run-up to the
festival the rehearsals and concerts
come thick and fast whether studying or
working many young Latvians spend almost
all their free time with their choirs
singing gives me lots of energy our
conductor puts everything he had into it
and I feel recharged with fresh energy I
feel wonderful said that did this was
lovely shaded we're gonna choir you have
to accomplish things together because we
all sing together awful if one voice
sounds really good but the others are
bad everything sounds bad nessuna
Elizabeth Mona and her friends from the
choir like to stroll through Rigas
streets in the evening but even then the
main topic is the upcoming song and
dance festival it's a cornerstone of
latvian national identity
miedo that my boss gave me the week off
for this and I don't even have any
vacation days but this festival only
happens once every five years he and his
family will be celebrating right along
with us on its first day the festival
starts with a parade hundreds of choirs
marched through Riga all the singers
wear traditional costumes of wool and
linen santosh vandals hillocks you see
how they celebrate how people stick
together yeah I think the most important
part of this is simply being here all
together buddy go case miss us a core
part I think classical linen fabric is
just beautiful but to be honest today is
just far too hot for this costume a
singer might have said the same thing at
the very first Latvian song and dance
festival 140 years ago festivals like
yet have a long tradition in all three
Baltic countries now they're even on
unesco's world cultural heritage list
here in the old town the morning before
the grand finale inst Esther off skis
recalled that it was here that he first
discovered the real power of folk songs
when Latvians marched for independence
from the soviet union in the late 1980s
acquires played a key role
many laughs Ian's even speak of a
singing revolution mom be what they seem
shocked what are taught the spilt star
singing together created very strong
feelings of community back then it's
Malik's well Toby bobby pin for the
first time in my life I was proud to be
a lot vsop a dirty business lock fits
the singers begin to gather outdoors
near the stage
trannyth today we'll all be together
here 15,000 singers and 15,000 audience
members the song festival is the main
thing that brings our little nation
together letting our fifth recent war
bug thousands of singers take their
places on the stage the choir poses for
a quick group photo to remember the
occasion after all the next latvian song
and dance festival won't be until 2018
the singers on the stage strike up the
tune and thousands of viewers join in to
form one single resounding voice and
finally over now to the UK where
summertime is a bit of a dodgy affair at
the best of times but the Brits are not
ones to let a little weather dampen
their spirits they have a wealth of
entertaining summer events to pass the
time and we may only hear about the
well-heeled a skirt races and the hats
but many ordinary Brits flock to the
country to let their hair down in proper
english style the great yorkshire show
in northern England is one of the UK's
biggest agricultural fairs London is
really the center of British cultural
life but here for three days the people
of Yorkshire have a chance to show off
John Henderson has been coming here
every year for a decade it's a farming
show by farmers for farmers but as well
as that very important most of the
people who come are not farmers but they
want to know about their food about the
countryside but it's also just you know
lad have fun it's a good day out for the
Breeders the show is a success if people
are impressed by their livestock ideally
the judges impressed to his approval is
marked with a red bow everything for the
best orders there's some other colors
you'll see like the age groups the
restaurant of that age kind of thing
anyways let's go to get milked the
beagles championship is a serious
competition these representatives of
British hunting dogs are busy at work
just looking cute Garner's no points
must have a strong shoulder some strong
back to push it along with because these
these hands hunt for a long time all
through the day and they had to be very
fit and very strong the Great Yorkshire
show was first held in 1837 the goal was
to safeguard the future of farming six
thousand visitors came to the first show
today it draws 130,000 many people use
the occasion to put on a spectacle of
their own but even those without the
right outfit are welcome to try on top
quality country styles by regional
designers
trying something like this is amazing
she's not necessarily going to find it
in the shop so it's my purchase for the
day and when the Sun shines even in
Britain it's picnic time
can we put tortilla wraps with ham and
cheese and then for later it is good to
tougher and tougher
the aristocratic equivalent of the
English passion for the outdoors is a
skirt near London for 300 years it's
been the meeting place of the Royals and
the upper class that's part of why
people here in Yorkshire are proud of
their identity and their show
jaysus Steadman is a professor at a
Berlin research center focusing on the
customs of the British the took after
slam fear in the country they developed
rural activities is a conscious contrast
to the hustle and bustle of the big city
in the capital there are also an answer
to the snootiness of the English upper
class Gazette's en among the more
eccentric summertime sports in England
are the annual cricket match on the sand
bank in brambles on the southern coast
or the watercress eating contest in old
food near Southampton and the
traditional cheese-rolling contest in
Gloucester she always sees its fair
share of injuries the foot down for once
they can stop restraining their emotions
in their bodies and maintaining the
facade of decency things that dominate
everyday life they let their hair down
and can briefly just be wild and have
fun yeah afterwards it's back to normal
orderly life don't have sushi bars and
I'm happens if you don't let him give
you that out right
whatever their social class the British
love gardening the great yorkshire show
devotes an entire event to crops and
flowers we all love gardening I think it
goes back a long time to when people
grew their own vegetables have little
cottages and leave your vegetables you
grew flowers and one protected the other
so people got used to it and the more
urban we become the more people love to
have their own little bit of god john
henderson can't imagine spending his
summer anywhere else but in the
countryside and before you know what our
time is up that is all for this edition
of our euromaxx highlights so until we
meet again all the best from berlin and
a few dozen
you